[Music]
let's all know what
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we saw some pretty crazy comments that
we didn't originally see on the show
what do you think about how people
treated her tonight and how things
should go with her moving forward well I
think all in all she got off kind of
easy tonight just based on all the on
the footage that I showed and everything
and she's a very polarizing person for
us and for the audience watching
obviously but I kind of I must say they
just like to play devil's advocate and I
think that there was a lot of things
that crystal got a lot of flack for that
other women did not like the logic
didn't carry through just because some
people liked other people better which
isn't really fair you know what I mean I
think she has a little bit of
narcissistic tendencies but I don't
think she's a bad person you know I
think that I think that everyone handles
this experience differently and she even
said herself it really kind of didn't
show her her best sides who do you think
crystal really is I don't I still don't
know I still don't know I not that
curious to find out you know I respect
her as a human being from afar she's
interesting you know at some points I
would see her smiling in the corner and
it really freaks me out because I didn't
know if it was genuine or not but that's
what makes crystal crystal and she gave
us some good content I was really upset
I was really upset hurt and don't judge
me for
you